the alternative to innovation is not
stability it's stagnation hi I'm Nick
Gillespie with reason TV and today we're
talking with Fred Smith he's the former
head of the Competitive Enterprise
Institute at which he's the emeritus
head of now and he runs the Center for
advancing capitalism Fred thanks for
talking to us I always led be unique the
Center for advancing capitalism this is
the mission statement it engages both
business people in free market
intellectuals in the fight for liberty
by building doer thinker alliances
through research writing events and
other outreach activities the center
works to recapture for capitalism the
moral legitimacy it has always merited
let's start with basics how are you
defining capitalism in this context
capitalism fighting in many ways they
course originally or did the term partly
invented by his critics remarks and so
forth capitalism I think is best defined
as an extensive system of voluntary
arrangements between parties embedded in
the institutions of Liberty that is
extensive and involving property rights
voluntary agreements allow people to
reach a wide array and growing array of
contractual obligation it's kind of like
it's it's partly it's the economic
application of classical liberal
principles of autonomous economics
arguably it could be any kind of
arrangement south area but essentially
the classic examples are risk sharing
arrangement some and as we know when
certainly reason is done a lot of work
on today's world we're never going to be
adults under the FDA rules because we're
not allowed to say I'm willing to assume
risk you signed those papers when you
get operated on I have two new
replacements but let me assure you look
at those papers you know it says no
matter what happens you're not going to
do anything well five lawyers have
learned years ago you can run a truck
through those kind rules what are the
actors and who are some of the actors
that have dragged capitalism's
reputation into the gutter and talked
about you know how do we know that
capitalism does not have a moral
legitimacy or is capital as you know if
you talk to a leftist they're like holy
cow everywhere I see capitalism is
winning throughout the world
globalization has increased ownership
but you know has increased private
ownership
around the world so what's going on well
polling data suggests that in the United
States and Europe the the original areas
were capitals in broke out very large
numbers of people do not find capitalism
acceptable system they think something
better exists out there they not sure
what it is and certainly it's not
socialist very often at least the United
States somewhat more in Europe the
general argument is that capitalism is a
good idea but and then dot that dot and
you end up with all the very end
hyphenated capitalism inclusive
capitalism state capsule is your crony
capitalism with a human face a big fan
of that but so what well you know what
is it you know when you look at somebody
like Donald Trump who's everywhere right
now and he's a capitalist he says he's a
capitalist and he's a bully and he's a
blowhard and he lies about its net
wealth is that where capitalism loses an
aircraft support clubs Trump has always
been in the political economy working
with the Pluto system and to some extent
if you're a developer in urban America
state any George politicise their
jurisdiction the the deal-making with
your partner on the other side then
so-called public-private partnerships is
a way of life it's inevitable we
government as big as it is there would
be interaction between business and the
political system the tragedy is so often
at least the subsidies rent-seeking the
kind of operations which essentially the
capital so okay and then there's there's
people like Martin shkreli the
pharmaceutical company executive who
jacked up the cost of the hell is he
responsible for a bad face of capitalism
or is he a good capitalist well I think
in a way those are the aberrations weeks
in Iran but if you look at this is a
book by a Jerry Miller I just finished
reading it's a history of sort of
philosophical attitude shows capital
runs a Greek so onward and you see that
every criticism of capitalism you can
imagine it alienates man for man it
turns humans into robots in the
workplace it destroys our ability to
enjoy the aesthetic non-economic
destroys the physical planet it takes
from the poor and gives to the rich
cultural and undermines the cultural
traditions the
the challenge as anyway as we have a
whole intellectual tradition going way
back but certainly exacerbated after the
progressives came into power in the late
19th century which essentially creates
capitalism as a at best and an
instrumental immoral amoral way of
advancing wealth and knowledge but
distributed badly doesn't handle it very
well creates inappropriate it uses means
rather than focusing on the ends of the
good society you have both on the right
and the left criticism capsules and go
back right that affects the culture and
culture has a massive effect culture
essentially is the ocean their
atmosphere in which we are breathing
swim and the result is whole generations
of America grown up in a yes it's okay
but right and our side has spent most of
our energies the free market
intellectuals which start emerging
really in the late post four hour period
forty-eight one bubble in society reason
sixty the Libertarian Party 71 Kato CIA
yo where and then a ho plus plus and
another in America around the world of
the state level right but late and our
focus following Hayek's victim was to
fight the war of ideas in other words a
Meyer intellectual and moral arguments
against our opponents in the
intellectual left one of the groups who
is the most difficult to convert or even
persuade because the self-interest of
intellectuals as Jupiter and others have
pointed out is Theta ISM liat moral
superior they capture the moral high
ground you care about money and things
in business we care about people and
then of course is the state grows the
role for well-paid powerful advisors not
only in government but in business every
business now is sort of a mirror image
Environmental Protection Agency vice
president for Environmental Affairs
human resources areas vice president for
human and on and on and on intellectuals
benefit from the state and that makes
their intellectual bias reinforce and so
there it's not that we can't persuade as
many goes for lefties at one time but
boy it's an uphill battle so what is the
moral case for capitalism or what is the
moral legitimacy of
apolis well first then this is one that
all of us more or less focusing on its
most compatible with liberty as a
voluntary system nobody is coerced to
buy from a firm to work for a firm to
supply to affirm to invest in the room
that is an attribute that means that we
are essentially creating pleather sites
every day where you want to work where
you want to buy from and so on and that
illustrates at the market in a very real
sense is one of the most democratic
moral institutions you can have because
it expresses the will of the people in
their society but is it also is it
distinct from a pragmatic or utilitarian
case so somebody like Joseph Schumpeter
said you know that it allowed people to
kind of take goods and distribute them
more fairly it's that it was constantly
creating more and more goods a cheaper
and cheaper prices and he used the
example that you know it's not that it
produced silk stockings for a queen but
rather the factory girls who made the
stockings could afford them themselves
democratized so I mean is the moral case
clearly distinct from a kind of
pragmatic case that because a lot of
leftists and certainly this was true
throughout most of the Cold War they
would say well you know what you know
actually capitalism it produces more
blue jeans more cars better cars better
colleges etc better yeah we win the war
on utilitarian grounds but utilitarian
ground secrets are just one of the core
values that anthropologists talk about
of evolved through man's history we
don't extend those values in other ways
for example we have that as with to the
wealth of nations which illustrates just
how incredibly creative the voluntarist
achsah stem is in creating spontaneous
order creating this web of cooperative
networks that extends throughout the
world where people have no idea what the
ultimate end of their product is
nonetheless contribute to a pencil and
are many other things out there but they
feel to a we've failed I think today to
adequately other we've done it
intellectually to adequately understand
that is people we're social animals Adam
Smith wrote another book the Theory of
Moral Sentiments which said yes we're
self-interest in a very powerful way a
survival instinct that had you exist but
we're also other regarding a pathetic
why because the social animals how do we
ever get to
we have to win some sense put ourselves
in the skins and the minds of other
people if we're going to engage in
society and man is a social animal we're
not like tigers who can't get along with
each other although libertarians might
be more than Depp but we generally are
speaking as we're social animals which
means we do have an empathetic sense and
i'm smith wrote eloquently about that
you're walking on the street a guy trips
you sort of wins that means in effect in
our business conversations the economic
linkages we create I see as a massive
template a trellis as it were to allow
human standard act on a limited
incorporate on economic grounds but in
so doing no business conversation for an
hour is not going to involve what do you
do when your interests are with your
families what are your hobbies so who
are black creates a social linkage not
economic linkage and those social
networks extend outside the firm and so
the market not only creates a web of
involuntary economic reactions it is the
best facilitator for creating the rich
social networks which copies the modern
world where does charity or philanthropy
cut or non profit driven activity fall
into this and what is the proper scope
within a business to do that so and are
their businesses that you think do a
good job of delivering quality goods at
high prices with with you know fantastic
service but then also serve the
community in a way that is not you know
simply kind of cheap PR or does that
matter if its appeal yes matter I think
the distinction between what a company
should be doing and what companies till
they're told they have to do and then a
sort of morally blackmailed into doing
it's very distinctive a corporation is a
special it the corporation incidentally
is the one where most of the fires
driven right capitalism is amorphous
system and people say well it works but
but it's cheap institution acquire Nader
doesn't mind capitalism eh corporations
okay the corporation is the main
institution that most people see when
they seek out those other solutions
partnerships private companies and so on
but they see the corporation is somehow
an impersonal big forest that is
distorting but the corporation is it's
not operates with internally as one of
the most cooperative and
evers out no company no good manager
wants to do anything other than good
relations with our customers their
employees there are investors they're
there the suppliers now they can family
that dads this always been true or I'm
because you know one of the things we're
taught in history is you know well
Carnegie is you know calling in the
Pinkertons to shoot his striking miners
so is that actually whereas does that
story have to be proven well it has to
be proven one and you know the muckraker
judicial and again that was what I
learned about early capitalism to
remember we learned about the monopolies
of the trust and how they were riding
roughshod over and then later on we find
out that the prices are dropping faster
in the trust areas more and more in
materials being available mankind to
organize and deliver the fruits of
capitalism the utilitarian value
capitalism forms corporation some is
very very largely managing a large
institutions a difficult situation and
often there are aberrations which make
an art but good management is always
striving for good you don't want to
antagonize any of your economic
cooperation can avoid it and to do that
you have to be thinking about what they
want to do now it doesn't mean you have
unlimited responsibilities for the world
the idea the leftist idea the social
justice idea responsible for everything
is a recipe for disaster because profits
are an incredibly important way of
creating a northstar a metric that helps
you sort through well maybe another
better lighting for the workers or maybe
higher pay or maybe the suppliers would
need more early payments or maybe my
investors would want to know more
reporting of what my investment schedule
is for the next thing there's tremendous
things that you can spend your residual
money on profits very diff in a very
difficult way says think of all the
opportunities you have to invest to deal
with one of your co-operators to make
the relationship more cooperative and so
on and then try to figure that good
managers are better at that than bad
managers people in the business world
who do that well but all of that is
limited by the fact that is to improve
your overall ability because you think
you're doing good things to be
sustainable to be sustainably profitable
survival is important if you believe
you're doing a moral thing and so in
this case I mean part of the advancing
an understanding of capitalism and its
legitimacy is also to say that
businesses are not responsible for every
aspect of human life they can't be right
because once now it doesn't mean that
another institution could be formed to
do so know whether it's a non-profit or
inert or even a government program
hapless in by creating greater wealth
and knowledge makes the viability of
those other non economic institutions
much better but when you start blurring
distinction between the two you lose the
metric you're a top manager and I'm
fortune 500 company and you've decided
you're going to be socially responsible
which way she's not very sure what that
means but you look around you're not an
expert in sociology or human welfare and
so on you read the newspaper and it says
the cars this year is age or the cause
this year's African poverty or maybe
it's a child home pregnancy or whatever
you know II thousands of material you're
going to be influenced as much as
anything but what your cocktail party
people have said why aren't you doing
something about are you kid comes home
from school says daddy why you
destroying the planet the thousands of
social clues that have nothing to do
with your expertise your capability the
idea that a corporation should abandon
its specialized role which is an
incredible essential element of a
capital system and become a
general-purpose organization that's what
governments are and nobody thinks
governments are doing a very good job of
delivering their attempts to be
everything to everyone you know an
increasing number of people when you
look at polls that beat up you or gallop
or everybody who does them shows an
increasing number of people really think
that the system the system life is
rigged against them that business is
rigged against them are they you know in
the wake of the financial bailout where
some people got made completely whole or
even more than whole other people got
nothing you know they got the shaft up
but you know from policies they had no
control over but ended up screwing up
their their lives and their jobs are
people wrong to think that the system is
rigged well the system is rigged in a
certain way but they need they're wrong
to pick their picked the wrong criminal
the basic argument is market should be
allowed
be free to operate and they should that
means free to operate and free to fail
what we've created and we this is
inevitable political process it's always
trying to protect the past is trying to
protect the vested interest the powerful
interest of business of the past
government to a large extent instincts
are to help people in place and in job
skills so they're always trying to help
the the buggy industry of yesterday and
the innovative industry of tomorrow is
so scary to them it's disruptive they're
not pleasure and then they the exemplary
case of this right now is something like
uber where you have a new system that is
voluntary that people love regulates
itself and the first action is to try
and save taxi you know taxi systems that
were in place in Italy one of the
interesting things is competent that's
the other point is the internally
corporations want to be cooperative
externally competitive competition is
the force that continuously makes him
think are we doing the right things and
they can see that in their profit margin
their customers different parent hire
worker turnover there's plenty of ways
that competition disciplines the
business community in a way far more
effectively than a political process it
also discipline then and you you know
you hear their certain people you know
we joke about another kind of
libertarian world like I'm going to
discipline that guy with with the market
by not going there it also disciplines
workers who don't have skills and and it
might be because they're lazy but it
might be because they're just not up to
the task what happens then a people who
are disciplined into poverty by the
market that's one way of putting it
another way of putting it is is that the
economy like the ecology is a dynamic
process trees are always dying and
certain skill set certain capital
equipment certain sectors the economy
are always stating out dying out you can
try to stop that process you can try to
creep their own trees alive forever and
in the process you suppress the growth
of the only hope we have for the future
the alternative to innovation is not
stability its stagnation and as bad as
the disruptive effects that are
certainly present in a
in a dynamic captor economy the
alternative is the stagnation is also
planned economy yes oh and nobody where
I would hope nobody would say yeah you
know in order to preserve X number of
taxicabs uber is banned Oh some people
try yeah in some places but
overwhelmingly you know / figure that
way to sue for peace but you know with
workers who are displaced by economic
disruption and innovation creative
destruction what you know what is a way
that a from a capitalist point of view
from a libertarian from a market
friendly point of view that we can help
ease those transitions without stopping
the process which is absolutely
necessary to improve step look what
capitalism does is empower people it
empowers people to think not only about
today but about their future we spend
people go to college even though they
know that that period is that can be
economically productive people go to
work at its startup jobs so McDonald's
and so forth not because they want to
stay there but because it gives them
certain skills that then equip them to
take other jobs elsewhere markets are
about good relations with the worker for
the markets some markets is just a
mining town and so forth the
understanding is that's a short-term
position our financial industry now I'm
you know there are some brilliant kids
who go into the financial world and they
burn out ten years and most of the the
the the history now is replete with
people that they earned a lot of money
they learned some job skills and then
they go into something else who rest of
life though a dynamic economy means work
skills whatever your work skills are
today they're not going to be the
richest you need tomorrow capitalism is
making that more and more apparent to
people but not surprisingly some people
run traditionalist value but also unions
and so forth want to freeze the present
but if you freeze the present you kill
off the future and in the world where
young people to continue seeing me born
and where older industries are
stagnating the only hope for most people
in the world and certainly outside the
United States all the people who is to
continuously create new opportunities
new innovations ubers of the future so
talk a little bit about the specific
sorts of activities and arguments
you know that the center is
participating in and that you think
we'll be able to change people's
understand I mean do we need to make it
more explicit and more persuasive the
argument that you're just making which
is translated into look the problem with
policy wonks as we're walking okay we
have to find a way of taking our
academic remember the problem is some of
our stand electrodes are in the
university system and you do get paid
for talking to people in those places
you get talked you get paid for writing
abstract articles with lots of
mathematics that appear in non readable
journals and non non representative
places none of that is real is useful in
reaching out to our potential allies in
the capital system the businessman the
capitalist himself we need to find a way
of taking our intellectual ammunition
which is good and reformat it
recalibrated going from nuclear bomb
theory to you know 22 22 round small
caliber material this like I think you
might be losing people who are squirrely
about guns so talk about the what I mean
is it we need to recalibrate our
argument so they reach the people we
need you i was out that means
businessmen and then in a way they can
reach their workers or suppliers every
business needs a story about why they're
not only proud to be business been doing
what they do but why they feel that
their operation actually is good for
society and workers should understand
that their suppliers their industrial
because those people who are economic
co-operators need to be in a sense
non-economic ambassador or their certain
businesses or businessmen or writers
that are doing this well and what can we
learn from them I wish I could tell you
there's a massive under provide resource
out I don't think there is most
businessman are pragmatic right they
said schumpeter said this he said wait a
minute we're producing goods and
services were providing jobs so on it
not enough no it's not the utilitarian
arguments are good for the first century
I would say the first century of
capitalism 1778 ill 1850s pretty good
Europe any haces but then the people
started raising what about the other
non-economic rising we all know those
exist in their part for our wise the
naturally important for others and we
never really
went and generalize the arguments one of
the challenges of our movement in our
people to do that but we haven't done in
a way that moves it out of the
conceptual sphere into the kind of thing
you can talk at a bar stool you think
you can go to a cocktail party and the
businessman can blow the hell out of his
liberal academic for so uh what about
you know I'm thinking of the you know
various people over time and Conrad
Hilton the hotelier wrote a very popular
speech in the late fifties out why he
opened he was attacked by right-wingers
and by anti-communist he opened a hotel
in Moscow and he gave this great speech
that was like well what I'm doing it
there is I'm destroying them because
when they see what we serve I so things
like that is that getting towards what
you're looking for but the problem looks
like Maki Maki the only ways a very
admirable but businessman he runs a lot
more place and so I but conscious
capitalism suggests that capitalism
needs to do more it doesn't say that it
sort of suggested one of my our friends
Martin Somers in England wrote a piece
called conscious capitalism is not
totally without merit but what we really
are failing to realize is unconscious
capitalism the equivalent in the non
economic sphere of the spontaneous order
the capitalism creates as template for
much richer social networks it makes
people more considered of others in it
enhances our in pathetic senses because
you're not gonna be a good businessman
unless you have an ability to read the
other the very concept of he's a good
person to do business with means you
didn't walk away from that with 99
percent of the games you didn't walk
away sin boys can i skin that guy that's
there are people who do that in the
business grow they're called sharp
dealers and they're not considered the
kind of people you want to do business
with the business community the the
existence of the modern corporation is a
force for making mankind more
cooperative and more disciplines
competition makes it more discipline the
nature of the firm and its incentive
structure makes it more outreach as
somebody who has a checkered history as
a government regulator right
you know it were are there times when
even good capitalists just are not like
that where they're like well screw it
I'm dumping all of my used chemicals
into an open water supply and if so then
what what do we do then is there is
there a role for non-market generated
regulation of business and business
practices first let's look at the
question why would anyone dump they
would not have dumped their trash that
plank load in your backyard because it's
private property what we have done in
the progress is really in a Jimbo's but
the rivers were never owned the Hudson
River was never know in England in the
early Industrial Revolution fishermen
had rights to fish along a river and
when the pollution started killing the
fish they went to court one the
railroads the farmers had a right to
grow their crops when the railroad
started sparking and burning this is all
in early gross okay Ron yes but what the
government did because these were now
very powerful economic interest they
they change the law and change the
liability rules to effectively allow
dumping of sparks dumping of a surface
of what do we do now then is a dubbing
do we go back to that or do we you know
or I mean I'm saying what do we do
moving forward especially if we're
trying to create a revolution where
business is seen as morally legitimate
capital is like what we have to let's
take the easiest example that I can
think of this the United States in the
world have two important liquid
underground resources one is oil which
because of a property rights expansion
in the 18th 17th century allow
subsurface ownership rights and mineral
rights okay I own the land on the
mineral rights but I can sever the two
and i can sell an all company or company
buys this little piece not very useful
but all companies have very incentive to
unit eyes it create a pool and then
learn what's there and so forth this
last two weeks you California groups to
do this you found a massive underground
aquifer was found in the Central Valley
of California it was found incidentally
because the oil industry is mapped out
all the united states and their data
showed where the water reserve was but
nobody can own that res
we have no subsurface mineral water
rights to ownership so they and the best
amount of potable water on the planet is
not rivers in labor it's groundwater if
we could turn we could create a just an
option we don't have to turn it over
Adam our money but allow anyone in an
area who can acquire property rights and
then can say we would like to own the
aquifer we've got local groups who own
the underground they're above the
aquifer we'd like to own that in here so
I plan to do it and manageable and so on
they would then haven't sent him not to
dump pollution in that ground without
accurate they would have reason to try
to replenish it more quickly when there
was a rainfall they would have reasons
to utilize that water and price it so it
was not wasted and so on we failed to
allow the market to move into areas and
because we didn't have them we had no
markets in those areas the market didn't
fail the market was outlawed then we
have regulations coming where the market
has failed we have to do it much of the
environmental issue much of the
electromagnetic spectrum where we ban
the ownership of the electromagnetic
waves we can modify the law in in
resource area after resource area to
allow groups under certain circumstances
to petition the current political body
owning that resource of managing that
research for privatization options say
we would like to own that here's why we
think we do a good job we will submit an
annual report a code by those and then
reopen the laboratory of markets to
begin to show how markets can resolve
these problems feeling a property rights
approach we slip into market socialism
which is the Soviet Union tried for
years um you know one of these things in
the you know over the past 40 years say
you know going back to the early 70s and
which we might say is the start of the
official kind of doctrinaire libertarian
movement the focus has always has really
been on economics and one of the things
that you talk about here is that that
can only take you so far what is the
role of culture and how do we how do we
work into that space oh you have the
rich Virginia postural did a very good
job of living is in that direction and
others have begun do that dieter
McCloskey obviously is moving us in that
direction we've got to do a lot more in
that area but we also have two coloured
ins
I narratives tend to be economic nurses
even basi odds narratives is a
provocative as they are have not turned
France into a libertarian Haven somehow
we have to reach the you know the
standard crochet their hearts as well as
a mind but to do that we need evocative
stories we need stories and we've done
some of these stories about what the ban
on genetically modified organisms is
done to the hopes of African farmers how
in other countries like Brazil and
Argentina somewhat freer societies GMOs
now revolutionize it but a European
elites Manning trade from African
countries that use modern technology
have condemned whole populations there I
job should not be to tell the story in
Washington or in London but to bring the
African voice more vocally to the
surface we could tell i mean we out of
the power of the crying baby on
television where are our understanding
of how we tell stories that evoke the
charitable responses the empathetic
responses the people people are not
opposed to capitalism they are opposed
to the caricature that is shown
government in bed with government and
and and businesses playing games that
are fraudulent games with corporate
social responsibility all right well we
will leave it there we have been talking
to Fred Smith who ran the Competitive
Enterprise Institute for so many years
and so well the Center for advancing
capitalism which is part of the
Competitive Enterprise Institute check
it all out at CEI org for recent TV I'm
Nicholas me
you